hi I'm Chris Bane's an engineer on the
Android developer relations team and I'm
here today to give you an introduction
to actionbarcompat so when it's
actionbarcompat well it's a support
library that we released this week as
part of the support library version 18
which allows you to add at a compatible
action bar to your application but
allows it to work from Android 2.1
upwards now actionbarcompat has been
designed to mimic the action by api
available in later versions of the
platform as much as possible which makes
your job easier
so how as you actually go about adding
it to your application well there are
two ways we support first is there
Gradle and it's been added to the
android support repository which means
it's a one-line change steal build up
Gradle as you can see here or
alternatively you can add it as a
library project you should have a look
at the support lobby release notes for
more information on both these so if the
rest is dead by I'm gonna go for a
scenario and that scenario is that you
have an application which works on Ice
Cream Sandwich and above but you want it
to work on devices from 2.1 and above
instead the first thing we need to look
at are your resources specifically your
menus and your stalls so actionbarcompat
includes free styles which you must use
I've heard directly or indirectly and
they are themed I can pack theme that I
can pack that light and theme that up
compact that light that dark action bar
now the key node of you will see that
each of these mirror a theme from themed
at holo and they act accordingly so back
to our scenario we have in our manifest
we have an activity which directly uses
the themed holo light dark action bar
theme now this comes from the Android
system now to change this fraction bar
compaq we need to use the theme from
action bar comma instead so that will be
the theme that I can Pat that light dark
action bar female but most applications
don't use this and they don't use themes
directly they have customized themes so
here we have a small example with a
theme called themed off styled which has
a parent of themed at holida light which
has a custom action bar theme and that
that that style it is referenced below
now for actionbarcompat we've had to
import a lot of active
it's interaction my compact which you're
after then use so there are two rules
you need to think about the first is
that your style must always have an app
compat apparent and secondly you must
always double set each attribute once in
the android namespace then again in the
default namespace so back to our
scenario theme that star would become
this so rule number one has to have an
app compat the parent so here we've
changed it to a theme but I can Pat the
light and then rule number two you have
to double set each attribute
now the we've already set it in the
Enver namespace as we need as you can
see so we need to copy that value and do
it again in the default namespace which
is the second bit in green so that's it
we styles as long as you follow those
rules you should be fine so following on
with that with menus so as with the
standard action bar items are added to
it they're the options menu now we
recommend you add and we have their menu
resources so here is an example menu
resource with one item a search item and
that item has an action view plus a
reference in a search for you now the
curve of this is that it has two
attributes which were added in honeycomb
so you can't use them before we can but
they'll be ignored so to get around this
we think we've sort of imported all of
the action item related attributes
interaction bar compact so to do that
you need to import them into your
namespace now we've called it the your
app namespace but it you could call it
anything you want and the result is that
you need for any of the action item
attributes you need to reference them
from this namespace not the unfort no
space so that's it with your resources
and I going to move on some code so the
first unit of indirect is your activity
your activities need to extend from
action bar activity now action bar
activity it was added in action bar
compact and it actually extends from
fragment activity itself that means you
can continue using fragments but you
must use the support implementation and
then as I mentioned earlier the API
we've tried to add two actionbarcompat
is very similar to that of activity in
later releases of Android so we have a
get support action bar method which
we returned you an action bar which has
a near-identical API to that action bar
available in honeycomb ICS so you can
add tabs change the navigation type or
it's changed the home item to act as up
navigation another method you'll
probably use he starts the port action
mode which will start a contextual
action bar now as I mentioned earlier
you add items to your action bar via the
options menu so here we have the so
here's an implementation that you would
do in Android one version one where your
override on create options menu and you
inflate a menu from your resources now
nothing is changed inspect this exactly
same as you do have action bar compound
the only difference is when you want to
start calling methods which were added
in honeycomb or later such as get action
view we have here to get the actual
reference to the search view now too to
get around this in action bar compa
we've added the menu item compact class
which is a collection of static methods
which will allow you to reference these
methods cleanly and safely much like you
do with a lot of the other support
methods now we move on to fragments now
nothing is changed with fragments you
can ticking you can continue to use
Android support the v4 dot fragment as
you always have and indeed to add items
to your options menu from there you just
need to call set house options menu join
your oncreate
and then your oncreate options menu and
I'm prepared on just a minute will be
called and you inflate them just like
you're doing your activity I hope this
makes your lives easier and thanks for
watching